alors on va passer un terreau du nul
bien alors l'interview nul vous allez
voir c'est très très con c'est normal ça
s'appelle comme ça donc sinon ça
s'appellerait pas l'interview nul voila
est-ce que vous préfériez d'hitler ou
staline gens préfèrent aucun mais on
compare pas donc c'est super et choisir
je choisirais certainement pas hitler
aujourd'hui
la dialectique 14 années déjà dans le
quotidien et le courant alors tiens
voilà imaginez que vous croyez la
réincarnation vous préféreriez vous
réincarner en giscard balladur ou
raymond barre terry a maintenant mais
c'est à vous être amis de tiberi je
préfère pas être un cas non non je vais
pas me répondre ça choque pas c'est
l'intérêt composé de schiste car giscard
balladur ou bar voilà c'est un jeu parce
que balla diop à ce que moi je fais rire
les gens oui d'accord sympa je me
demande vous avez été
bien est-ce que vous donnez plus de
circonstances atténuantes écoutez bien
les compliquée celle là à à des vieux
qui se tape des jeunes ou à des jeunes
qui tapent sur des vieux car les jeunes
qui tapent sur des vieux ouais ils ont
plus ce concept innovant de nord - à
moins de circonstances atténuantes ah
ouais non c'est moi qui a renversé la
crise d'accor donc il vaut mieux être un
vieux qui se tape des jeunes 15 jeunes
qui tapent sur un vieux d'accord entre
pas de sexe et pas mangé pendant dix ans
vous choisiriez quoi
compliqué compliqué le camarade
sexe parce que si vous mangez pas
pendant dix ans toute manière il n'y a
pas de
selectica encore dialectique toujours
alors imaginez qu'on soit aux sports
d'hiver tous les deux dans un chalet
bloqués par la neige moi je meurs de
faim on n'a plus rien à manger je meurs
de faim et vous vous avec moi à manger
vous commencez par quoi
le cerveau le crb on dirait pas pourquoi
haha
pourquoi non le cerveau le cerveau alors
il est obligé de partir sur une île
déserte alain krivine vous préféreriez
partir avec un mec très beau une fille
très laide jeudi avec très beau une
fille tracy pour y rester de longs mois
une fuite relève ah oui quand même vous
n'êtes pas du tout peur mais bon là
c'est du tout dit mais ce n'est pas une
injure du tout du tout pour moi d'accord
non mais pour moi non plus alors un ami
débarque à l'improviste chez vous si
vous ferez le plus au monde qui découvre
sur la table de nuit le livre de claire
chazal ou un godemichet
y en a qui est un outil de plaisir
paraît-il oui le livre et l'autre qui
est bon enfin bref donc oui non plus
plutôt le livre de claire chazal vous
préfériez qui voit le livre de claire
chazal quelques nord qui voit plutôt le
godemichet
bien alors on va voir si vous allez bon
coeur est-ce que vous échangeriez votre
paralysie générale vous serez paralyser
toute votre vie pour qu'ils aient plus
de famine en ethiopie
je dirais non parce que le reste est
mensonger ouais donc j'ai un nom je me
battrais pour qu'il y ait plus de
familles en ethiopie pour ça faut pas
dire pas du mali paralysé tout faire il
faut pas être paralytique pour empêcher
la famine pose pas il fait mal à 10 ans
le mec a discuté avec les copains
pendant des années très bien